[موسيقى]
نحن في الايام الاولى من السنه الميلاديه
20 23 وهي سنه بسيطه فعندنا سنين وبسائط
وسنين كبائس البسيطه عدد ايامها 365 يوما
ويكون فيها فبراير 28 يوما والكبيسه عدد
ايامها 366 يوما ويكون فيها فبراير 29
يوما وعدد السنين البصائق اكثر من السنين
الكبائث في التاريخ فكل اربع سنوات يكون
عندنا كبيسه واحده وثلاثه بصائر بمعنى ان
الذي يولد في يوم 29 فبراير لا يحتفلوا
بيوم ميلاده الا مره واحده كل اربع سنوات
وجيه للطيبين مثلي مواليد واحد رجب واحد
سبعه لا يحتفلون في تاريخ ميلادهم ابدا
ليه لانهم ما يعرفون تاريخ ميلادهم من
الاصل لله جيل الطيبين كانوا كالطو ديما
ذلوا ولا استكانوا هم كالغيوم سابحات بدلا
وكالنخيل الباسقات
فضلا
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
وسنه الكبيسه اكبر من السنه البسيطه بيوم
واحد ليش لان الحسابات البشريه بين قوسين
التقاويم لم تستطع محاك الدقه حركه
الاجرام السماويه الشمس القمر الارض فيكون
فيها نسبه خطا مقداره ربع يوم في كل سنه
يجمع هذا الخطا ويجعل يوم واحد كل اربع
سنين سنين الجندي انطالت ستطغى لها امد
وللامد انقضاء امانينا لها رب كريم اذا
اعطى سيدهشنا
العطاء
[موسيقى]